you know they say that you can't go home
again but if you can do the time-warp
again maybe you can also go home again
[Applause]
[Music]
so patreon sponsored review and this one
was an interesting one I've got two
patreon sponsor reviews this month which
was kind of cool that's a first
um so shock treatment the kind of sort
of sequel to the Rocky Horror Picture
Show
I've never seen this before I knew it
existed I think most rocky horror fans
certainly at least know it exists I
don't know how many people are actually
seen it it's it's a thing okay boy how
do I even start explaining this thing
well let's start by its actual relation
to Rocky Horror Picture Show it's got a
fair number of these same people
involved the big ones being the director
Jim Sharman I believe is his name
and Richard O'Brien who played riff raff
and also wrote the music and came up
with the story for our picture show is
back in those same capacities and
playing a new character excuse me
Patricia Quinn who played magenta she's
also back on now Campbell played
Columbia she's she's in it Charles gray
you played the criminologist he's in it
and we also have four returning
characters we have previously incredibly
minor characters from Rocky Horror
Picture Show Betty and Ralph HAP shat
that's the couple getting married at the
very start of that movie they appear in
this and in addition Brad and Janet are
back though that's a little odd because
of all the returning actors they were
able to wrangle they did not get Barry
Bostwick and Susan Sarandon so it's odd
that the recurring characters they
brought back they didn't have the
original actors but okay
boy where do I begin with this thing
okay let me kind of jump to the end and
say this doesn't work but it's kind of
fascinating to sort of pick apart and
figure out why because on paper there's
a lot of carryover between this and
Rocky Horror Picture Show in terms of
the kinds of weirdness the people behind
it the type of music because yes it is a
musical you know the general feel and
vibe it's very very similar and it and
it obviously is intended as a kind of
sequel to the Rocky Horror Picture Show
and yet somehow it doesn't all pull
together let me try and tackle the plot
this is not gonna make any sense
alright and because it was funny I
watched it I'm like I'm not sure I
understood that then I looked up a
synopsis of it and I was almost kind of
hoping the synopsis was gonna reveal to
me that I was like completely wrong and
what I thought I understood except I was
mostly right which you know I guess
that's in its favor but that means I
kind of followed it but it still didn't
make sense okay so there's a town called
Denton but it's also a TV studio that
the entire population of which is either
making and a appearing in or serving us
the live audience for TV shows Brad and
Janet arrived they're now married and
Brad is he's just well he's emotionally
stunted and kind of a wet blanket and
Janet's starting to get annoyed with him
for that they appear on this sort of
game show thing that the upshot of which
is Brad gets committed to a mental
hospital which is also a TV show it's
kind of a soap opera and that is run by
a somewhat unnerving doctor and his
sister that's Richard O'Brien and
Patricia Quinn
and now Campbell is there as a No
their hair is also you know that I
mentioned the HAP Schatz is Betty HAP
shad who's kind of a news reader and she
is she and Ralph are separated and she
is hooking up with Charles Gray's
character who is a sort of a so-so see a
lot sociological sort of guy I think she
says she he's a judge and they're kind
of hooking up and looking into stuff
though I'm not entirely sure why and
then Ralph he is also a sort of a
presenter and he is shacking up with his
co-host and there's also a blind weird
German guy played by Barry Humphries
otherwise known as Dame Edna and there's
also a fast-food magnate who just bought
the town / news station and also there's
like a twist with long-lost twins down
the line and Janet has turned into a
local celebrity and and Jenna's parents
are there too and did ya if you made any
sense out of that then you've done
better than I have and I think in many
ways my inability to explain like even a
basic premise set up of this it kind of
cuts to the heart of what doesn't quite
work which is that as weird as Rocky
Horror Picture Show was because it was
weird it builds the weirdness over time
and it also gives us an initial sort of
stable grounding in Brad and Janet
because they are so normal at least
initially and when you're because
ultimately the starting premise of Rocky
Horror is ordinary couple goes to weird
house cool and then the weirdness
happens in waves it happens in layers so
you know normal couple goes to weird
house okay there's some weird people
there alright there's a very
host okay he's also a scientist who has
made a sort of a Frankenstein alright
and like we're like but we're doing the
weirdness one after another but not all
at once which is kind of what shock
treatment does it really doesn't show a
lot at you right from the get-go and it
makes it really hard to find that ground
and find that place to get your feet
underneath you and actually wrap your
head around what the heck is going on
you're playing catch-up
pretty much the entire time now I do
want to say that as much as structurally
it would appear that chalk treatment is
very much a cash-in sequel you know get
everybody that we can back and basically
do kind of the same thing I don't get
the same level of cynicism from it that
I usually get from that kind of setup I
do get the feeling that Richard O'Brien
and Jim Sharman really were trying to
say something and do something a little
bit different with this and I do think I
do get a sense of passion in this though
I think that also contributes to part of
the problem the fact that they were
trying to do something because even
though Rocky Horror Picture Show has a
lot of undercurrents and a lot of layers
on a lot of subtext and brushes past and
incorporates a lot of themes it's not
really strictly speaking about any of
those themes not explicitly so you know
there's all the stuff about you know
kink and accepting who you are and you
know everybody's weird and that's all
they're but that's not what that's
that's not what the plot is actually
about whereas in shock treatment they
are trying to very flatly and obviously
do you know have something to say about
consumerism about modern entertainment
about the lie of the middle-class
American dream about fashion about
mental health yeah it and trying to like
have something to say about all this
stuff adds to the awkwardness of it
overall I don't want to slam it across
the board though because there there's
definitely some good stuff in here
um some of the music is actually quite
good I don't think any of it Jeeves the
the highs of rocky or
but there are some good songs the act in
the titular song shock treatment is a
good one also I really liked a little
black dress that was a pretty good one
there were some others as well but there
were also some that was like okay and
though this is a little bit nitpicky but
this threw me off too well actually I'll
put this in the broader context of the
recasting of Brad Janet which I kind of
touched on so while there's nothing
really bad or wrong with these actors
they're not barry bostwick and Susan
Sarandon and I don't mean to be that as
a slam but you know the right heel
British oh it lucked out with some of
its casting cuz pretty much none of
these people were big names at the time
they were used but a fair number of them
had very strong couriers afterwards sort
of proving the like wow we got lucky
snatching them up before they were big
and these two don't have that going for
them and I also really threw me off this
is the nitpicky thing that this Janet
has a much slower singing register than
Susan Sarandon did Susan Sarandon sang
very high in rocky or Picture Show like
almost deliberately squeaky at some
points
this one was got a very deep singing
voice and that's not inherently bad or a
worse way to sing and she does it
perfectly fine but I know rocky or
feature shows so well that that threw me
off something fierce I'm trying to think
where else I want to go with this like
it it has so many components and so many
pieces that were present in Rahil
bridger show yet they just don't quite
come together and I think it is a
combination of missing sort of the the
pacing a Rocky Horror Picture Show and
just throwing all the weirdness in at
once which like even for somebody who
loves rocky or is show is kind of too
much you know I was still trying to wrap
my head around this whole thing of like
wait it's a town but like everyone who
lives in town is in this is in this TV
studio I didn't even really get my head
wrapped around that before we got into
the next the next weird thing that I'm
like wait now what
now what wait wait wait uh and you just
kind of feel burdened by all of it but I
think ultimately well first of all let
me be very clear I'm glad I saw it um
and actually I might look into whether
or not I can buy like some of the
individual tracks like like on Amazon or
something or if I'd have to buy the
whole soundtrack album because depending
on price I might not be up for that but
there there are some there are some good
songs basically any time Richard O'Brien
and Patricia Quinn were on screen
especially if they were singing I was
kind of in rapture because I find those
two immensely magnetic I always have so
you know that was really good stuff some
of the songs are actually also really
well shot in terms of choreography and
camerawork some are also incredibly dull
as a weird sort of upshot of the TV
studio conceit - they kind of overuse
the you know head in a TV screen as a
default bit of imagery and it's it's
boring I'm sorry it just is but yeah
nobody nobody feels like they're phoning
it in they are trying and I think that
effort does elevate a little bit more
than just well that didn't work no and
it didn't work but it also you know it
felt like it came from from a good place
from good instincts and so I would sort
of label it under its it's an oddity for
fans it's a bit like when a you know a
music artist had a weird experimental
concept album that was that you know
somewhere along the line that maybe it
didn't work but if you're a fan of them
maybe you check that out or to put it in
movie terms I would recommend it on the
similar basis that I'd recommend
something like the Doctor Who TV movie
that had Paul McGann and like it's not
good but if you're a fan of Doctor Who I
recommend you watch it because it's an
interesting oddity with some good
elements or if you really like the
Beatles if you haven't seen it I would
recommend that you watch the movie
across the universe it's not a good
movie
it's an amazing mess but if you are
watching through the filter of that
fandom I think you'll still get
something out of it that's worth getting
and I feel the same about this with its
relation to Rocky Horror
and it's appealed to that same kind of
thing that said if Rocky Hort was not
your bag this will really not be for you
although you know if there's anyone out
there who likes this but doesn't like
Rocky Horror Picture Show
I'd love to like sit down and have a
conversation with them pick their brain
figure out how that worked so shock
treatment have you seen it probably not
but if you have would you think about it
and if not what are your thoughts on
anything that I've said drop them on
down in the comments and let's talk
about a whole bunch of stuff you can do
because there's buttons and links
there's a Pio box the patreon plus a
whole bunch of other stuff it's all down
in the description so check out if you
want to if you don't that's okay too
because you know what at the end of the
day you're the council I just run the
meetings and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]